this is the police General Hospital in
central Bangkok where Texan shinowat was
admitted just after midnight on
Wednesday morning
showing symptoms of high blood pressure
and low oxygen levels the Corrections
Department assessed he'd be better
monitored here
Texan a temporary reprieve from his
first night in jail
his political allies were having a
better night
nominated by the per Thai political
party and endorsed by Parliament as
Thailand's 30th prime minister
I would like to thank every time the
Coalition parties honorable members of
parliament and Senators for taking part
in the vote today
for many ties their new prime minister
is relatively unknown a real estate
magnate he only entered politics last
year
running on a joint ticket for per tie
with taxin's daughter petongtan it was
never clear who was the Prime
ministerial pick
when the party came second in May's
general election setar became the
default choice
himself doesn't have a political backing
from being in politics and his own power
base and then the party he's working for
uh doesn't have as much leverage as it
used to in the past
the new prime minister will also have to
manage a complicated coalition
government including three
military-backed parties
the inclusion of those parties will be
unpopular with voters who overwhelmingly
chose parties of Reform at The Ballot
Box
and those parties May pay a heavy price
for their cooperation
with all eyes here at the police
Hospital on the condition of former
prime minister Texan shinawa it perhaps
takes a little bit of the pressure off
the new prime minister but he faces an
uphill task with a difficult coalition
to manage and a voting public who didn't
necessarily choose him for the job Tony
Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok